le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
la
santé est assez bonne à la Réunion mais
l'importation de certains produits
alimentaires est encore trop importantes
alors que notre île dispose des
conditions idéales pour la culture et
l'élevage en pleine nature de certaines
espèces nous continuons de faire venir
des denrées alors que nous avons la
possibilité de le faire ici à la Réunion
par des Réunionnais mais le principal
problème est la disponibilité des
terrains agricoles alors comment
attribuer des terres à de jeunes
agriculteurs motivés on en parle
maintenant dans les liens social
Emmanuel est un jeune homme ambitieux
fils d'agriculteur cagnier il connaît
bien le métier et ses difficultés déjà
éleveur de cabri ils souhaitent
développer son activité
passionné par son métier il aimerait
augmenter son nombre de bêtes mais
Emmanuel n'a pas l'espace qui lui faut
pour atteindre son but Emmanuel apprend
que le département propose des aides en
attribuant des terrains en friche
propriétés du conseil général à des
agriculteurs ayant un projet de création
ou de développement c'est donc tout
naturellement qu'il s'est renseigné pour
monter un dossier lui permettant
d'obtenir un terrain à moindre
fraisement j'ai postulé pour les 0,5
hectares de mon caprice
sur lequel je souhaitais m'installer le
terrain quand même va falloir faire des
analyses de sol terrain quand même bien
en friche bien enclavé il va falloir
tout défricher maintenant suite à ça je
pense demander des subventions au
département pour pouvoir
mener à bien mon projet et diversifier
ma culture bon j'ai quelques peu visité
le terrain j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
bâtiment dessus un bâtiment abandonné il
y a il y aurait un priori aussi une
culture soucière parce que j'ai vu qu'il
restait des morceaux de serre bon je
compte peut-être les défricher pouvoir
ensuite ou déplacer que mettre d'abord
tout un planning peut-être remettre la
tête dessus parce qu'il y a quand même
quelques rochers il y a des arbres à
battre il y a quand même pas mal
d'arbres est-ce que maintenant il va
falloir demander encore les
autorisations c'est pas des cultures
protégées ou pas
mais ensuite ce que je souhaiterais
faire sur ce terrain ça va être du foin
dans un premier temps parce que c'était
le projet de base
faire du foin afin de rationner mes
animaux parce que j'ai quand même
quelques cafpins je compte faire grossir
mon troupeau les élargir maintenant
ensuite m'installer peut-être dans sa
culture
ben lors de l'appel à projet on a été
plusieurs candidats postuler pour ce
terrain
tu as été retenu suite à
un échange
c'est entretenir avec les responsables
il y en a eu plusieurs candidature elle
est là mon projet apparemment coïncidé
par rapport à la surface
maintenant le Conseil général
parce que j'attends le terrain assez un
terrain tout de même
avec un terrain irrigué c'est un terrain
où jusqu'à l'électricité dessus donc
maintenant est-ce que je vais pouvoir
faire des CRS est-ce que je vais faire
tout en entier du foin
Emmanuel et bien conscient qu'il y a du
travail à faire pour pouvoir exploiter
au mieux son nouveau terrain mais il est
aussi conscient et heureux de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un terrain et des aides
nécessaires au développement de son
activité le Conseil général met un point
d'honneur à ce que l'agriculture à la
réunion soit soutenu pour permettre aux
Réunionnais de profiter de ses propres
produits locaux cette initiative
volontariste mise en place par Nassima
d'un dar a beaucoup d'avantages sociaux
et économiques la terre à la Réunion est
chère et la terre elle est rare
également si bien que beaucoup
d'agriculteurs ne peuvent plus
s'installer et en même temps c'est un
métier dont on a besoin pour produire
les les légumes comme les fruits à la
Réunion les bons et c'est pour ça que le
Conseil général nous mettons et nous
valorisons toutes ces friches pour les
donner à jeunes agriculteurs qui
s'installent en même temps nous passons
j'ai envie de dire de la Solidarité
sociale à la solidarité économique mais
créons également les conditions de
l'emploi et nous conditions nous créons
également les conditions au fond de la
bonne alimentation du produit sain de
l'autosuffisance alimentaire qui reste à
atteindre pour la Réunion comme Emmanuel
beaucoup d'agriculteurs réunionnais
aimeraient avoir la chance de pouvoir
créer ou agrandir leur exploitation les
terrains deviennent de plus en plus
rares à la Réunion pourtant nous avons
encore besoin de produire nos propres
fruitiers et légumes d'élever nos
propres animaux cette possibilité de
pouvoir exploiter des terrains
actuellement en friche est une des
solutions avec aussi par exemple la mise
à disposition par le Département de
certains de ces espaces naturels
sensibles qui font avancer la réunion
comme la plupart des dispositifs mis en
place par le Conseil Général celui-ci
démontre une fois de plus que le
département continue de soutenir tous
les Réunionnais dans le maximum de
domaines
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais